starting to feel a little bit like it's
coming to an end we've got the entire
cast back together hey guys I'm Kelsey
nighttime at PaleyFest Parks & Rec is
reuniting have to be ten years we
haven't been together talking about the
show in a really long time it's very
emotional it's great I'm just gonna cry
my eyes out all night this is gonna be
really moving we have a game Aditi
called eat eat up which is basically one
after another you're gonna ask the next
person on the carpet a question did they
secretly record me naked in my trailer
define record if I record you mean
sketch in charcoal you're right I do you
give us a fun question which cast member
made your favorite noises with his or
her body that is so annoying because
Nick and FRA used to fart all the time
and it would make a me and I really
angry so I don't appreciate that
question and I'm gonna say pass and what
do you want to ask the next person in
line
ask her who her favorite cast member is
who's my favorite cast member Jim o'heir
because he was my my trailermate and he
used to go get me food when I didn't
want to go what question you want to ask
the next food when I don't want to go
what question do you want to ask the
next star where'd you get that suit our
costume designer from Park stressed me
tonight Kirsten man and Leslie always
would wear some kind of like red when
she was feeling full of love actually
she that was like this is her love color
red or orange so we wore that tonight
[Music]